it is down these cliffs that a lava fall
is flowing towards the atlantic for the
cuba family the worst could not be
avoided josiah construction worker
listens in horror to the advancing lava
the home he built with his hands the
ones of his parents
sister aunts and uncles
all gone
loss is all that has been gained from
this eruption he says
it's frightening at night we watch this
red line tearing us apart we're all in
pain suffering from this disaster
while the airport has reopened
commercial flights are grounded a thick
layer of ash hangs over the island
authorities are asking people to stay
indoors wear goggles masks and avoid the
coastline
the problem that people are facing is
irritation in the respiratory tract and
the eyes and of course the contact with
the ash with the skin is extremely
noxious with the lava reaching the ocean
there is a sense of panic amongst
tourists stranded on the island no on
the east side it was a little bit better
[Music]
now it's
it's worse i guess so yeah of course
we're concerned
yeah i think
it's time to leave the island now yeah
the shoreline of la palma is what marine
biologists describe as a hot spot of
diversity home to pilot whales manta
rays and blue sharks species that are
about to encounter explosive in hot lava
destroying some of their habitat
from above the extent of the volcanic
activity and its subsequent damage
becomes visible volcanologists had
predicted that there would be an
eruption but had not anticipated its
magnitude they say since this all began
the island has increased in landmass
it's as if cumbraviera with this
eruption is pulling the island of la
palma out of the ocean it appears the
120 thousand-year-old island is going
through a growth spurt but in its path
it's destroying people's lives as if
it's reclaiming its right over this land
nicholas honk al jazeera tessa corte la
palma